i i i i i i'm curious what every like
zombie
story and like every like every kind of
like apocalyptic story
like would like how if 2020 would have
changed like how
cliches and trolls are just gonna get a
million [ __ ] boring movies about this
current pandemic and you know
can you make an exciting movie about the
pandemic i mean they tried to do it with
2012 right
they made one like in 2006 or something
like who was it
oh it was pandemic right that was a
little pandemic there's like a few
movies that like
that are like worryingly close to like
what happened yeah that was the there
was the one that i
that went viral i think i saw it last
year um
it was like crazy yeah yeah yeah in the
movie there was like a pandemic that was
like completely obviously
named something completely differently
years before and uh
and i think it got viral because people
found it on netflix
and started watching it and the dead
asked the plot is that there was a virus
that was started
in china through bats really yeah and
people were like yeah some chef had it
and he shook hands with the business
woman
yeah and then and then it spread to
america and then like half of america
died
he's [ __ ] mad i think it was man
i love you right there and people are
like oh my god this is almost scarily
similar to what's actually happening
right now so probably smarter because
people probably acted much a lot smarter
in that movie i don't know
no no no really they were done well then
but in that movie as well they would
just like instantly die
yeah yeah for some reason matt damon and
his kid i think we're immune
to the ones that were immune because of
course matt damon i'm pretty sure if
that happened matt damon and tom cruise
be [ __ ] immune to him yeah
matt damon i think matt in the movie
matt damon was like i quarantined for
two weeks
never mind i'm immune now
stayed inside of a room for two weeks
and then the doctor was like guess
you're immune now
it's a pretty good movie have you have
you watched it i've just seen clips of
it
yeah it's pretty good it's pretty funny
watching it now being like yeah that's
[ __ ] weird
it must be weird watching it during the
pandemic and saying being like
this is uh this is uncomfortably close
to what's happening now it just makes
you
realize like how lucky we got that it
could have been way worse like it could
have just immediately killed people yeah
because i i think you know we we've
obviously gone through a really harsh
period right now but i feel like
humanity really just got like we got the
best warnings yeah yeah this was this
was the best warning sign that
we could have gotten and i say this
obviously knowing that you know it's
it's a [ __ ] tragedy how many people
have died but
the the scary thing is that it could
have been so much [ __ ] worse
yeah than it was and this was this was
kind of like the worst case scenario for
how easily transmittable this virus
could have been but
in terms of like in terms of like its
actual effect it could have been a lot
worse
and i say this with the [ __ ] awful
results we've gotten
so far i mean it's just it's just scary
to think that you know if this had
happened
you know 50 100 years prior yeah like
how much
probably much much much worse it could
have been you know it's weird because i
i've been thinking about this a lot
because it's uh it's been like a full
year now
since since i remember thinking oh this
is gonna this is gonna last a few months
this is there's this quarantine thing
right this is a this is a little
this is a fun little everybody came
together like we'll bunk up for like two
months and then you know we'll be able
to go outside and enjoy the summer
i remember the joke was like oh anime
nerds haha i found
i i was born for this yeah and then i
kind of you realize pretty soon that
there's a big difference between
choosing to stay home
and being forced to stay home there's i
don't know what it is but there's a big
[ __ ] difference
i saw a tweet that was like man are
people gonna judge people who have a
tough time readapting
to social situations right i was like
what
what do you mean what do you mean
re-adapting like people who have been
uh like in live in their house for too
long alone
they were like i hope we don't get
judged what they're suddenly going to go
outside being like how do i interact
with humans yeah yeah
i thought it was a little odd what do
you think they like
you agreement
i've been i've been in the joint for too
long i don't know how to reacclimate to
society but it was just like
you don't you see [ __ ] like that on
twitter and it was just read something
like
it was like it they they made it out
like it was way more serious and like a
big issue than it was and i'm like
bro it's literally talking to people
what are you what are you how is this
i know people you know struggle to
socialize but acting as if like
your life has just been flipped upside
down and it's going to take so much
readjusting like you
like to get over this i'm like bro it's
like it's like it's not like you trying
to learn
a language that you stopped learning
afterwards maybe this is a shitty take i
don't know it could be a shitty take i
i was just like what what am i doing am
i dumb well you're obviously
not part of that right hashtag obviously
i you know i know i'm quite extroverted
and i
obviously can't sympathize 100 with all
introvert problems
but like you know i mean to me i was
like it kind of seemed like they were
trying to make it like
i don't know because sometimes twitter
does this where it's like guys guys
i have a problem guys i need to tell you
about my problem guys please come on
fellaini
i believe that i believe that's called
first world problems yeah maybe yeah
maybe
yeah or it's like the woe is me right
well i don't know like i
i can kind of understand but at the same
time how is it going to be different
like how are you gonna how is it that
much different from what you were like
before yeah it's like it's like
it's normal yeah i mean it's like no
one's gonna force you to go
outside after the pandemic if anything
people are probably gonna just don't
worry about it just
go back to being we'll just go back to
the situational people we're choosing to
be inside
taking a flight going on a plane
it's like if you were you know if you
loved being inside before the pandemic
you're probably still going to be inside
after the pandemic let's be real
no it's like the police aren't going to
come and be like all right you've been
in this room for too
long all right get the [ __ ] out get the
[ __ ] out you got it you gotta put a
little
water on myself he's missed your mouth
it's been